the space that you kind of touched on
that's full of theories and
is perhaps detached from
appreciation of empirical evidence or
longing for empirical evidence or
grounding in empirical evidence is
the theoretical physics community and
the interest in
unifying the laws of physics and
with the theory of everything
it's i'm not sure would from which
direction to approach
this question but how far away are we
from
arriving at a theory of everything do
you think
and uh how would we
how important is it to try to arrive at
it
uh at this kind of goal of this
beautiful simple theory that unlocks
the very you know fundamental basis of
our
nature as we know it and
you know uh and how what are the kinds
of approaches
we need to take to get there yeah so in
in
physics the biggest challenge is to
unify quantum mechanics with gravity
and i believe that once we
have experimental evidence for how this
happens in nature
in systems that have quantum mechanical
effects but also gravity is important
then the theory will fall into our lap
okay but the mistake that is made by the
community right now is to come up
uh with the right theory from scratch
and you know einstein gave the illusion
that you can
just sit in your office and and
understand nature you know when he came
up with his
general theory of relativity but you
know first of all
perhaps he was lucky but it's not a rule
the rule is that you need evidence to
guide you especially when dealing with
quantum mechanics which is
really not intuitive and
so there are two places where the two
theories meet
one is black holes and there is a puzzle
there
it's called the information paradox in
principle you can throw
the encyclopedia britannica into a black
hole it's a lot of information
and then it will be gone because a black
hole
carries only three uh
properties or qualities the mass the
charge and the spin
according to einstein but then when
hawking tried to bring in quantum
mechanics
to the game he realized that black holes
have a temperature and they radiate this
is called hawking radiation and
it was sort of anticipated by
jacob beckenstein before him and hawking
wanted to prove beckenstein wrong and
then figure this out
and so what it means is black horse
eventually evaporates
and they evaporate into radiation that
doesn't carry this information according
to hawking's calculation
and then the question is according to
quantum mechanics information must be
preserved
so where did the information go
if a black hole is gone and where where
is the information that was encoded in
the encyclopedia when
it went into the black hole and to that
question we don't have an answer yet
it's one of those puzzles about black
holes
and it touches on the interplay between
quantum mechanics and gravity
you